المواجهات تتكرر في السودان والمتهم واحد
قبل اسقاط الرئيس السابق عمر البشير قتل
متظاهرون مناوون له عام 2019 والقيت
التهمه على جهه ثالثه بحسب مدير المخابرات
انذاك صلاح عبد الله غوش
انتهى حكم البشير وبعد اشهر من التنازع
السياسي بين المكونين المدني والعسكري حدث
فضه اعتصام القياده ايضا تكرر قتل
المتظاهرين وشماعه التي تلقى عليها التهم
لم تتغير
في وقتنا الحاضر هذه الجهه الثالثه ايضا
هي المتهمه باداره النزاع اول وقوف وراء
النزاع العسكري الدائر وهي قوه او فلول
نظام البشير السابق طرف النزاع تبادل
الاتهامات وفي مقابله مع العربيه قال قائد
قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو ان من
يدير الحرب على قواته هم قيادات في حزب
المؤتمر الوطني المنحل حزب الرئيس السابق
عمر البشير واعتبر انهم من يقودون الجيش
للح
مجموعه
من النظره الاولى
الارض
مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان رد ايضا
عبر العربيه مشيرا الى ان الجيش السوداني
وكاي جيش في العالم هدفه ضمان وحده الدوله
بشكل عام وليس العمل من اجل شخص او جهه ما
اذا
[موسيقى]
كذب ولا الجميع يعلم ذلك نحن قوات مسلحه
احترافيه وواجبنا حمايه السودان حتى
معظم هذه الاشاعه يعلم المصداقيه ويعلم
انه انها كلمه باطل اريد فيها
الاتهامات ايضا صدرت من بعض القوى
السياسيه لاتباع النظام السابق بالوقوف
وراء نشوب الحرب واستمرارها ومحاوله
تصعيدها خاصه وان العمليه السياسيه
الحاليه هي التي اقصت حزب المؤتمر
وعلى وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي يتداول
سودانيون ما يفيد بان انصار البشير يرفضون
صراحه قوات الدعم السريع لكنهم في ذات
الوقت يهددون بالوقوف بوجه الجيش حاله
توقف الحرب والهدف واحد مصلحه فلول البشير
حسن جوليد العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات